اذن من
الامطار الغزيره تسبب في شلالات في موقعي
البتراء الاثري الصور تتحدث عن نفسها الى
اي مدى بالامكان ربما تلافي الضرر او
الخسائر في هذا الموقع وهل سيتكرر المشهد
علما انه حصل عام 2018
الطبيعيه الا ان هناك تقوم بها السلطات
المحليه مشكوره منذ حوالي عقدين من الزمن
الطبيعيه المرتبطه بالفيضان حيث ان مدينه
وادي موسى التي تؤدي الى البتراء هي همم
100 كيلو متر مربع من المساقط المائيه عن
حدوث العواصف طبعا حاليا
الا ان البتراء بحمد الله تعالى وبفضل ال-
همم السلطات المحليه اعلنت عام 2012 مدينه
امنه ضد المخاطر الطبيعيه
2018 هل كان متوقعا سقوط هذا الكاميرا
هائل من الامطار في هذا التوقيت
مركز المنخفض فوق المنطقه الشماليه لذلك
يتركز التساقط على المناطق الجنوبيه هذا
معروف علميا وهذا يؤكد على حدوث تغير
مناخيه اكيد في المنطقه
وكميات التساقط ليست برغيبه عن المنطقه
امام التدابير الموجوده من سجود تحد من
همم مخاطر الفيضان والسيول وقنوات تصنيف
همم في داخل المدينه
المحيطه بالبتراء مدينه وادي موسى وداخل
البتراء واضافه الى
شبكات من قنوات التصريف المائيه من العهد
النبطي همم وجود انذار مبكر الرضوان
يعتمد عليه في مفوضيه البتراء اليوم
همم
السياح والاهالي من المناطق الحساسه اما
كميات همم احط فكانت يعني عاليه نسبيا
كانت 38 متر خلال يوم واحد وهذا كثير همم
للموسم وتبدا استاذ محمد الفرجات ربما
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي همم تحدثت عن او
اظهرت كما المياه التي تسربت الى مدخل
معبد البتراء الصخري
وبتالي نتحدث ايضا عن التغير المناخي من
جهه ولكن ايضا حمايه هذا الموقع المصنف
همم كتراث عالمي اما الاجراءات التي يجب
ربما ان تركز عليها السلطات الاردنيه من
اجل الحفاظ على هذا الموقع الاثري
نعم هنالك وظيفه البقعه تنموي السياحي
الذي اوجد عام 2009 كخلف اقليم البتراء
والبلديات هناك
ويقوم مشكورا حقيقه بالعديد من الاجراءات
ذكرنا منها تركيب نظام الانذار المبكر الى
الجواز من سلسله ضد الفيضان
لاخلاء المناطق الحساسه من ناحيه واضافه
الى انشاء سجود على مجالي الاوديه التي
تؤدي الى مدينه وادي موسى ومدينه البتراء
بالذات اضافه الى شبكه داخل المدينه
السياحيه داخل مدينه وادي موسى فضلا وجود
خطبه الطوارئ للتعامل مع همم الحالات هذه
الغذاء